my greatest guitar riff ever in TV so
yeah it figures you watch Power Rangers
as a kid then you become an adult ass
man you do YouTube videos you see a
trailer for the new Power Rangers moving
you're like I'm clearly not the
demographic but I got to talk about it
because it's in here we have a trailer
for the new Power Rangers movie coming
out and it's shave really clears up the
whole teenagers with attitude thank
those ones like all four riddles kept
her criminal term of teenagers with
auto-tune the Nelsons app sees kids up
he's like as best I could do
I mean I mean if by attitude you mean
successful in school liked by everybody
work with kids to give them a better
future with martial arts classes its
attitude I guess if I had to dude I mean
free well-rounded people this one they
are teenagers with attitudes they got a
detention every Saturdays pretty much
The Breakfast Club becomes Power Rangers
parents are yelling at the kids like you
go here every Saturday what do you want
to do with your life rah rah do anyhow
these teenagers with actual attitudes
get together and they go on a safari or
something and they run across this
prehistoric looking ship or a fossilized
formation with point is they have power
coins or buy power coins I mean power
rocks which makes sense if you know the
whole 10,000 years thing I imagine they
would be power rocks well press dinosaur
coins from 10,000 years ago just it's
interesting to me so yeah so they get
the power rocks and they become super
strong because they're becoming Power
Rangers I did like the scene where that
one dude that bully headbutts the dude
it's like a head-butting Superman or sub
thing dude just gets knocked out so
they're running hard they're jumping far
they come across what looks like their
command center and this thing starts
forming in the middle which might be
Zord on Bryan Cranston it's pretty good
casting for Zordon but we don't say him
and then the Venom symbiote starts
coming across their bodies and they're
going to become Power Rangers switch
alright like I said I do like the fact
that they're actually troubled teenagers
because it's just too clean to be like
hey you're good you eat your green
vegetables now you're a superhero that
worked in the Golden Age of comics but
by now I just need a little more damage
with my heroes and I do like the fact
that didn't show everything they didn't
actually show them in the Seuss they
didn't show sorta I could have gone for
a little bit of Zordon but I'm glad they
didn't show the Zords I don't want to
see the Zords in the teaser trailer in
fact if they don't show the Zords until
the movie I'd be fine with that I
treated like the Balrog from Lord of the
Rings fellowship with a ring just show
the foot and have that be that or a
silhouette from far
and again the action figure will come
out a month prior and then it'll be
ruined anyway so they might as well show
it I do want to know how Rita is like it
was she trapped on the moon or I imagine
they're gonna make it a dimension I
imagine they're gonna make it the coins
a little power rocks we're keeping her
at bay and trapped in her little
dimensional crystallized fossilized rock
vortex and then they busted it now she's
out and now they need Power Rangers
again probably would have been safer to
put her on the dark side of the moon
they just I feel like there's less
disturbance there it shows Rita floating
over a girl she's like I can't changes
this ha
the point is guys the trailer didn't
blow me away I'm not like oh my gosh
this is the greatest ruler ever but it
gave you a little taste and I'm an
optimist
Debbie granted my optimism has
disappointed me before in the past but I
can't help but be optimistic I want it
to be good I really do I want it to be
like the first Iron Man movie I saw the
trailer for and I'm like hey guess
what's gonna suck Iron Man and I suppose
I've been chasing the dragon ever since
for a movie that I so thought was gonna
suck and then ended up being so good I'm
not saying Power Rangers gonna suck I'm
just saying it's not like I'm like oh
this is the movie 2017 that's my film I
am saying it looks like a movie that's
on the razor's edge it could be great
for kids it could be complete garbage I
don't know and the fact is is too early
to tell it's just the fact of the matter
what do we know a group of troubled teen
Breakfast Club wannabes find power
stones and become Power Rangers that's
what we know now that's not enough but I
am curious as to what you thought of the
Power Rangers trailer so I will
officially ask you guys the first Power
Rangers teaser trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
you
[Music]